for the latest on the medical aspects of
the coronavirus crisis we're joined now
by a former Surgeon General of the
United States doctor the vague mortise
served during the last three years of
the Obama administration he's the author
of a new book with a timely topic
together the healing power of human
connection in a sometimes lonely world
that came out just last month dr. Marty
welcome thank you so much it's good to
be with you we are having some success
in reducing the amount of cases in death
states are reopening and loosening
restrictions but treatment options are
still limited and we don't know when a
vaccine will be here so what does the
next few months look like are we on the
right path well I think we have made
progress over the last several months
and we've made progress in a few friends
one is because people have made these
extraordinary sacrifices to stay home to
reduce their activity in their contact
with others we have been able to reduce
what it would have been a much much
worse peak of infections and deaths but
with that said we have still lost nearly
100,000 people to this virus and we have
well over 1.6 million cases and that is
actually still rising so we have to take
that into account and we still have to
be cautious
the second area where we made progress
is on vaccine development while we still
don't have a vaccine and likely won't
have one until 2021 we are seeing more
trials coming out with some early stage
promising results but any path to
reopening safely runs through testing
and this is the one place where if we
have to be honest with ourself we're so
struggling as a country because we still
don't have enough high quality tests
that are available to everyone who needs
them and that is posing a problem for
workplaces that want to open up and for
states that want to track the infection
closely dr. Marty it's Dana Jacobson now
you mentioned workplaces that want to
open and one of the workplaces so many
want to see open is in the sports world
I know you've consulted with the NBA and
formally and deal with some other sports
organizations when it comes to team
sports forget fans just about getting
back
the field or to the field of play how
realistic is it that we will see that in
the coming months well I think it is
possible for us to see sports history
started without fans because we won't
like they won't be able to see crowds
gather in significant numbers until we
have widespread immunity in the
population which essentially means until
we have a vaccine but with that said
there are plans and many leagues are
making to bring back the players so that
they can you start games and theirs can
at least be televised but to do that
requires a few things number one it
requires being able to test with great
frequency and what I hear from many of
the league's and from teams is that they
are one struggling to figure out how
they can get the volume of tests
required to test with that frequency
they're also worried about what it looks
like if a team is testing its players so
frequently when the people in the
community around it are still having
struck out of trouble on getting testing
so that is one big challenge the other
big challenge is how do you reduce your
risk of players getting infected in the
first place because we know that there
is still coronavirus in our communities
if players are going out into the
community coming back interacting with
the team and if one person gets infected
then you're at risk of having to shut
down the entire team so some leagues are
looking at whether they should
quarantine the players for the duration
of play that has implications for their
families and for their own mental health
so these are complicated decisions there
it's it's surmountable and i think we
will see sports over the next several
months but it certainly won't be easy
and again testing is going to be a
critical factor in terms of availability
obviously testing seems to be the key to
everything out there I want to turn to
your book now it deals with how vital
the human connection is and right now in
this time where even though places are
opening up we've had so much social
distancing what is your message to
people out there who still right now may
be feeling very lonely well first I just
want to say that loneliness was a great
challenge that we face as a country long
before the koban 19 pandemic and it is
normal to experience loneliness
throughout our lives it's a signal that
our body sends us that we're lacking
something that we need for a survival
which is human connection
what I found when I research in general
though is a loneliness was far more
common than I ever would have imagined
we have over a fifth over twenty percent
of adults in the United States struggle
with loneliness and many of our children
also struggle with loneliness this
affects how we perform in the workplace
in at school but it turns out it also
has profound impacts on our health with
loneliness increasing our risk for heart
disease for premature death for a
depression and anxiety but here's the
key is that loneliness is something that
we can address we can strengthen human
connection in our life and the reason I
wrote this book is because I wanted
everyone out there who was struggling
with loneliness to understand that you
are not broken and that you are not
alone that many people including myself
have struggled with loneliness over the
years but I also want us to recognize
that social connection is an
extraordinary resource that we have that
if we cultivate it it can be a
performance enhancer it can improve our
health and it can increase our
fulfillment and there's simple ways that
we can strengthen connection even in the
time of kovat nineteen when we're asked
to physically distance we can put 15
minutes aside to spend with the people
we love each day we can make sure the
quality at that time really counts by
eliminating distraction around us we can
look for ways to serve others
recognizing that small acts of service
are powerful ways of addressing
loneliness and counter-intuitively we
can also protect dr. Murray I'm sorry to
cut you off we are out of time it is it
is all good advice and obviously the
book is out there for people to find as
well we wish we had a little bit more
time for you but we do appreciate the
insight thank you